Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
(Voice off) Dear Alice, che cosa significa
prendersi cura di sé davvero?
Sono Alice,
e la mia missione quotidiana
è quella di guidare le persone
nel loro percorso di crescita
e scoperta personale.
E oggi, voglio rispondere
a questa domanda.
Per moltissimi anni ho cercato
di compiacere gli altri,
pensando che fosse sempre
la cosa giusta da fare.
Ma è davvero così?
A 25 anni mi sono laureata in ingegneria.
Non perché mi interessasse
particolarmente la materia,
ma perché volevo dimostrare a tutti
di valere qualcosa.
Ecco, l'ho voluto così fortemente
che ho fatto di tutto,
annullando me stessa,
per riuscire a conseguire il titolo
in tre semestri,
invece dei quattro standard.
Il giorno della laurea,
pensavo sarei stata
la persona più felice del mondo:
invece non ho sentito niente,
ero come anestetizzata.
E in quel momento, ho anche capito
che non era quella la mia strada,
e avevo deluso tante persone,
nel percorso - amici, familiari -
perché non c'ero mai.
Non avevo mai tempo ed energia:
ero troppo occupata a conseguire
l'obiettivo di qualcun altro.
C'è stato poi un momento, nella mia vita,
in cui il mio ragazzo di allora,
con cui convivevo,
mi chiedeva di cucinare con lui,
per lui, ogni sera,
nonostante sapesse quanto odiavo cucinare.
Sembrava la cosa più importante
della nostra relazione.
E l'ho fatto per anni,
pensando che questo mio sacrificio
l'avrebbe reso felice.
Ma mi sbagliavo,
perché gli anni non hanno fatto altro
che accrescere il mio risentimento
nei suoi confronti,
fino a farci litigare ogni sera.
E alla fine, ci siamo lasciati.
Negli ultimi quattro anni
ho avuto due figli, che sono meravigliosi.
è anche successo, però, tante volte,
che io mi sia annullata per loro,
mossa dalla fortissima convinzione
che una buona madre c'è
solamente se si annulla.
E questo ha portato
risultati controproducenti,
perché quando trascorrono
settimane, o mesi,
in cui io trascuro
me stessa e i miei valori,
inizio ad avere meno pazienza con loro.
E anche le cose più semplici,
come raccontare una storia alla sera,
prima di dormire, diventa un peso.
E in quei momenti, non mi sento
la mamma che vorrei essere.
Queste tre storie - quella della laurea,
quella del fidanzato per cui cucinavo
e quella della maternità -
apparentemente non hanno nulla in comune.
Eppure, in tutte e tre le situazioni,
con l'obiettivo di compiacere gli altri
e di esserci davvero per loro,
non solo ho fatto soffrire me stessa,
ma ho fatto soffrire anche le persone
che erano più vicine a me.
Ti è mai capitato
di svegliarti, un giorno,
e sentire che stai vivendo la tua vita
in base a ciò che gli altri vogliono,
e non per ciò che tu vuoi veramente?
A me, moltissime volte:
e questo accade
perché spesso prendiamo le decisioni,
e agiamo, per i motivi sbagliati.
Come quando ho scelto l'università
per compiacere le aspettative
di qualcun altro,
per poi trovarmi sofferente, nel percorso,
a non avere tempo, energie
per le cose che erano davvero importanti,
sprecando anni in quel percorso
che non era il mio.
Oppure per il forte senso del dovere,
come quando ho cucinato ogni sera,
nonostante fosse così lontano
dalla mia natura,
e nonostante avessi tanto altro
da dare, nella relazione.
Fino ad arrivare ad accrescere
un risentimento così forte,
e far soffrire la persona
che avevo vicino.
Oppure per il senso di colpa,
colpa che spesso non abbiamo davvero.
Come la voglia di rimanere donna,
oltre che mamma.
Però, questo senso di colpa
pesa così tanto sulla nostra coscienza
perché la società ci ha convinti
di cose come, ad esempio,
che una buona madre è una madre
che si sacrifica fino allo sfinimento.
Siamo stati cresciuti
con l'idea che essere altruisti
significa mettere necessariamente
le aspettative, i bisogni, i valori altrui
davanti ai nostri.
Io non ne sono più così convinta.
In aereo, prima del decollo,
ci ricordano che in caso di emergenza
è un nostro dovere indossare
la mascherina dell'ossigeno,
prima di aiutare gli altri.
E non lo dicono a caso,
perché senza ossigeno
non andiamo da nessuna parte.
Non ci siamo né per noi stessi,
né per nessun altro.
Come una studentessa
che sceglie la facoltà sbagliata
non potrà mai essere così brillante
da avere un impatto nel suo settore.
Come un uomo o una donna,
snaturati nella loro relazione,
non potranno mai essere dei buoni partner.
Come una mamma troppo stanca,
troppo insoddisfatta o triste,
non potrà mai essere
un buon esempio per i suoi figli.
Un essere umano,
per esserci davvero per gli altri,
per avere un impatto positivo
nella loro vita,
deve in primis esserci per sé stesso,
avendo un impatto positivo
sulla propria vita,
generando soddisfazione e felicità.
Ed è qui che entra in gioco
il concetto di cura di noi stessi.
L'avrai sentito, ormai è sdoganato:
"Prenditi cura di te".
Eppure ci sono tante
informazioni fuorvianti, sul tema.
Perché infatti, prendersi cura di sé
non significa farsi fare dei massaggi,
o bere dei succhi verdi detossinanti.
Prendersi cura di sé
significa scegliere di creare una vita
dalla quale non vogliamo
scappare ogni due minuti.
Significa, quindi,
scegliere di vivere una vita
in cui vogliamo essere
presenti e protagonisti,
per noi stessi e per gli altri.
Perché quando ci sentiamo
insoddisfatti, o persi, o tristi,
spesso non abbiamo altra forza
se non di occuparci
del nostro disagio interiore.
E non abbiamo niente per gli altri.
Avete mai incontrato, conosciuto qualcuno
che abbia voglia di scappare
fortemente dalla propria vita,
e esserci per qualcun altro?
Io no.
Ma soprattutto,
tutte le volte che io ho voluto
scappare dalla mia vita
non ci sono stata
per le persone che amavo.
Ecco, è qui il punto: prendersi cura di sé
significa avere il coraggio
di piacere a sé stessi,
ancora prima che piacere agli altri.
Significa avere il coraggio
di mostrarsi per come si è,
senza delle sovrastrutture
per poter essere più amati dagli altri.
Significa capire
che cosa ci smuove dentro,
per prendere quelle decisioni
che permettono di creare
una vita che ci appartiene.
Significa, in ultimo,
vivere una vita che scegliamo,
e non una dove gli altri scelgono per noi,
così da creare spazio, tempo e energia
per poterci essere
quando le persone più vicine a noi
hanno davvero bisogno.
E voi vi chiederete: e come si fa, quindi?
Io ho identificato tre passi.
Il primo passo:
riconosci i tuoi valori fondamentali.
I valori sono le nostre stelle polari,
sono quelli che ci danno la direzione,
che ci guidano, che ci motivano.
I valori sono insindacabili,
e sono diversi per ognuno di noi.
Non ci sono valori giusti
o valori sbagliati.
Attenzione perché i valori,
come vedete in questa slide,
sono diversi dagli obiettivi.
I valori sono modi di vivere;
gli obiettivi sono situazioni
che noi ci andiamo a creare.
Ad esempio, la laurea è un obiettivo,
mentre la flessibilità è un valore.
Ecco: quando vivi secondo i tuoi valori,
te ne accorgi perché sei completamente
allineato con te stesso,
ti senti in pace.
E nei momenti di difficoltà,
non perdi il controllo, rimani radicato,
e la tua vita continua ad avere senso.
Quando riconosci i tuoi cinque
primi valori fondamentali,
sai che potrai sempre aggrapparti a questi
nel momento in cui ne avrai bisogno
per le decisioni più difficili,
e inizierai a sentirti meno in colpa
perché ti accorgerai che non c'è colpa,
nell'essere se stessi.
Per qualcuno, questo significa:
lasciare un lavoro sicuro;
uscire da una relazione;
lavorare di più; lavorare di meno;
decidere di non avere figli;
Partire per una missione di volontariato
in un posto lontano,
sperduto e pericoloso.
Ecco, il primo vero passo
della cura è proprio questo:
identificare i nostri valori,
perché attraverso questi creiamo una vita
dalla quale non vogliamo scappare.
Come si fa a identificare i valori?
Chiudete gli occhi, e pensate,
tornate ad un momento
in cui avete provato
estrema gioia e felicità.
Quali erano le caratteristiche
di quel momento?
Cosa stava succedendo?
Magari era durante un viaggio avventuroso?
Allora magari è l'avventura,
uno dei vostri valori.
Allo stesso modo,
sempre scavando nel passato,
tornate verso un momento di difficoltà.
Magari eravate intrappolati, intrappolate
in un lavoro che non vi apparteneva.
Cosa stavate cercando?
Più libertà, più riconoscimento,
più flessibilità?
Ecco, questo è il primo punto
da cui potete partire
per iniziare a riconoscere
i vostri valori fondamentali.
E dopo averlo fatto, si può passare
al secondo passo della cura,
e cioè: ascolta i tuoi bisogni.
Ci sono tre aree importanti,
nella vita di tutti noi:
abbiamo l'area del lavoro;
abbiamo l'area delle relazioni;
e abbiamo l'area della salute.
Ora immaginate, per ogni area della vita,
di avere un serbatoio.
E per poter respirare
in ogni area della vita,
avete bisogno dell'ossigeno pieno,
in questo serbatoio.
Ogni qual volta ci discostiamo
da uno dei nostri valori fondamentali,
l'ossigeno inizia a scendere.
E così cosa succede?
Ci sentiamo soffocare.
Ed è quello il momento in cui iniziamo
a essere intolleranti, arrabbiati.
E proprio per questo è fondamentale
saper ascoltare i nostri bisogni.
Vi faccio un esempio:
Il mio valore fondamentale è la crescita.
Se io mi dovessi trovare
in un lavoro che è stagnante,
in un progetto che è molto statico,
probabilmente verrebbe fuori
il bisogno di evoluzione,
il bisogno di ricerca,
il bisogno di trasformazione.
E se io non dovessi considerare
questo bisogno, cosa accadrebbe?
Che inizierei a far soffrire me stessa,
ma anche l'organizzazione
per cui sto lavorando.
Perché?
Perché non sto dando il meglio di me.
Non solo io, anche i colleghi,
perché loro dovrebbero sopperire
alle mie povere performance.
E infine, probabilmente
questa insoddisfazione si riverserà
anche sulla mia vita privata,
quindi su mio marito, sui miei figli.
Allora è fondamentale
ascoltare i nostri bisogni,
trovare il coraggio e trovare lo spazio
per riuscire a soddisfare
i nostri bisogni.
Perché solo così riusciamo a riempire
i nostri serbatoi di ossigeno,
per poter tornare a respirare.
E come facciamo?
Mi direte: in queste vite così veloci,
dove è tutto difficile,
dove tutto sembra non dare
lo spazio per noi stessi.
Vite caotiche.
Attraverso il terzo passo della cura,
e cioè imparando a dire no.
"No" è una parola breve.
Solo il suono ci fa rabbrividire.
Dire no è difficilissimo.
Perché abbiamo paura di deludere qualcuno,
abbiamo paura di non piacere
a qualcun altro.
Abbiamo paura di essere giudicati,
di perdere un'opportunità,
di essere etichettati come egoisti.
Abbiamo paura che i nostri no
ci facciano sentire meno amati,
meno rispettati e meno riconosciuti.
Per me era difficilissimo dire no:
e attraverso i miei sì, però,
mi sentivo come diluita.
Mi sono diluita nel tempo, dicendo sì.
Perché dicendo no, ci creiamo dei confini
e in questi confini proteggiamo
noi stessi e gli altri.
E dire no significa, in ultimo,
dire sì a qualcos'altro.
E questo è stato il concetto
che ha fatto cambiare prospettiva.
Per cui io ho imparato a dire no,
perché ho imparato che se dico no
sto dicendo sì a qualcosa
che per me è davvero importante.
E ho anche scoperto che dopo un no
le persone ti vogliono ancora bene.
E ho scoperto
che le relazioni più importanti,
che i progetti più belli,
che le opportunità più grandi,
hanno bisogno della nostra attenzione.
Però quella pura, non quella diluita.
E allora, torniamo alla domanda iniziale:
che cosa significa
prendersi cura di sé, davvero?
Prendersi cura di sé davvero
significa accogliere la responsabilità
della nostra felicità,
ancora prima della felicità degli altri.
Perché non possiamo permetterci
di lasciar scivolare la nostra vita,
diluendoci per qualsiasi altra
aspettativa o bisogno altrui.
Non possiamo permettercelo,
perché sortiamo l'effetto
esattamente opposto:
e cioè non abbiamo più niente da dare.
È fondamentale sapere
che il nostro ossigeno
nei serbatoi è limitato:
lo stesso ossigeno che ci serve
per amare, per relazionarci,
per vivere, per lavorare.
E ho sentito dire
che prendersi cura di sé,
prima degli altri, è da egoisti.
Be', se respirare,
se esserci per gli altri è da egoisti,
ben venga questo sano egoismo,
da cui poi nasce
il più puro degli altruismi.
Perché senza cura non respiri,
e non puoi esserci
per nessuno, se non respiri.
Ecco: vogliamo un mondo migliore?
Possiamo iniziare da adesso,
agendo sull'unica cosa
su cui abbiamo davvero il potere,
e cioè prendendoci cura di noi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)